[Music]
to our other top stories tonight a
California Man is dead after a shooting
at Hard Rock Hotel in Lake Tahoe early
this morning according to the Douglas
County Sheriff's Office police responded
to reports of an active shooter just
after 8 A.M they found a man who had
been shot in the head he died from his
injuries several law enforcement
agencies responded to track down the
suspects Highway 50 in that area was
closed for nearly two hours
you know this is kind of the first
shooting here at the lake that we've had
thank goodness and so the response may
seem overwhelming and over the top but
that's okay all right
treated as an active shooter until it
isn't
Julian Delgado and Savannah Raquel
tatapale were arrested and booked into
the El Dorado Sheriff's Office jail
Delgado faces open murder charges and
tachapale faces GUI charges this is now
a homicide investigation